bonsoir nous sommes le 22 janvier
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction de tv fil 78 dans l'actualité
locale
aujourd'hui la commission régionale de
coopération intercommunale vient de se
réunir les nouvelles frontières de
l'intercommunalité saint-quentinoise se
précise le point et les réactions la
ministre de l'éducation vient de
dévoiler plusieurs réformes autour de la
question de la laïcité et des valeurs de
la république quelles conséquences et
quel est le sentiment des principaux
concernés les enseignants salon du
lycéen et de l'étudiant à versailles le
samedi 24 janvier des conférences des
stands afin d'échanger avec les
différentes écoles et universités ce
sera au palais des congrès tout au long
de la journée
la commission régionale de coopération
intercommunale a donc a adopté ce matin
la proposition de modification du projet
d'intercommunalité
versailles-saint-quentin massy saclay en
lieu et place d'un regroupement de huit
cent mille habitants
il y aura donc au 1er janvier 2016 trois
agglomérations une dans l'essonne une
extension de versailles grand parc à la
commune de ville de vélizy et enfin une
fusion de saint quentin en yvelines avec
plaisir villepreux les clayes-sous-bois
maurepas et coignières la casse qui
passera de sept à douze communes dans
quelques mois écouter le président de
l'agglomération
c'est une belle satisfaction savait
depuis le mois d'août dernier date à
laquelle le préfet de région a présenté
son schéma nous étions sur la menace
d'une intentionnalité à huit cent mille
habitants 57 communes et bien face à
cette proposition
nous nous avons su réagir en chine où
les élus et c'est vrai que l'amendement
que j'ai déposée avec mes collègues
présidents d'intercommunalités de
versailles grand parc europ'essonne et
de la caps et à cet amendement était
heureusement adoptée puisque sur 71
votants 69 ont voté pour cet amendement
et deux se sont abstenus
donc c'est une belle victoire qui nous
permet et bien de pouvoir rester dans
une intercommunalité qui sera à taille
humaine avec toujours de la proximité
ce dont j'avais très peur on parle du
grand saint quentin puisque parmi les
cinq communes qui vont peut-être entrer
parce que jusqu'à présent même si ça a
été voté il faut que le préfet fasse son
d'arrêter et sas interviendra qu en fin
d'année donc dans les communes
susceptibles voire d'heures rejoindre il
ya bien sûr des communes qui ont fait
partie il ya quelques temps de la ville
nouvelle de saint quentin en yvelines
le préfet doit rendre son arrêté
définitif d'ici la fin du mois de
décembre mais à moins d'un contrat
mandement ce qui semble plutôt peu
probable le nouveau territoire
devrait-on être ainsi défini il faut à
présent travailler ensemble écoutez
michel laugier travail et bien sûr sur
l'intégration de ces communes
parce que celles qui vont arriver de
front se mettre au niveau des communes
et qui existe déjà sur notre territoire
donc là tout le travail commence on
n'est pas encore au bout de nos peines
tout le travail d'intégration tout le
travail aussi de répartition des
compétences
et puis surtout l'impact que ça va avoir
sur nos budgets
pour dino budget le budget de la
communauté d'agglomération et le pitch
et des communes qui vont y faire leur
apparition
puis on parle aussi de la gouvernance de
cette nouvelle intercommunalité
parmi les cinq communes qui font partie
de cette nouvelle agglomération à saint
quentin en yvelines
une seule a fait part dans un déjà de sa
désapprobation c'est celle de coignières
la loi est la loi la loi est la loi donc
le maire de coignières devra appliquer
la loi
moi j'ai de très bons rapports
personnels avec henri paillet ben je
souhaite que l'on fasse des choses
en tout en toute quiétude et finalement
pour que tout le monde y trouve son
compte
voilà on moi je suis pas là pour
réquisitionner coignières je suis là
pour travailler avec one year ce qui est
tout à fait différent et on mettra
certaines choses en commun ce qui me
paraît évident en application de la loi
comme ça doit comme on doit le faire
henri bayota drôme république et moi
aussi autre réaction à présent celle de
joséphine coleman ce berger la maire ump
de plaisir elle juge ce rapprochement
logique sa vie il faisait partie par le
passé de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
dynamique de développement de ses
voisins lui semble similaire à la sienne
reste maintenant à savoir les bénéfices
qui en seront tirés écoutez donc si ça
qu'il va falloir voir parce que ce
rapprochement est un rapprochement je
l'évoquais lors de la cérémonie des
voeux de plaisir je disais rappelait que
notre but n'est pas et on est en accord
avec monsieur logis le président de la
caisse qui est pas de nous fondre dans
la quasi ce que l'on veut c'est de
retravailler ensemble pour pouvoir
justement avoir une réflexion par
rapport aux compétences et voir dans
quelle mesure on peut remettre à plat
les compétences aujourd'hui qui sont
celles de la caisse qui sait peut-être
une opportunité aussi pour eux de revoir
les choses de façon différente et je moi
je suis très optimiste sur le fait que
ça peut vraiment apporter une dynamique
aujourd'hui les collectivités ont de
vraies difficultés financières qui sont
très très lourde et j'espère en tout cas
même si effectivement il y a il ya des
problématiques financières un peu
partout même dans les agglomérations on
devrait faire preuve d'intelligence et
de pragmatisme pour arriver à réunir nos
forces pour le bien-être bien sûr de
tout le monde mais aussi pour ses
économies en ligne sans fondamentalement
aujourd'hui puisqu'on n'a pas le choix
et pour conclure cette séquence notre
question du jour que pensez vous de cet
agrandissement de l'agglomération de
saint quentin vers plaisir les
clayes-sous-bois encore maurepas voici
quelques-unes de vos réponses
monter un jeune dans la région
peut-être de maisons de votre réaction
on dit qu'il ya encore des mots voire
des espèces tant qu'il ya encore dix
morts alors c'est
capacités
je sais qu'il ya des communes qui
organisent avec des bus ils ramassent
les personnes fragiles emmène dans des
grandes surfaces
il avoue permettre de faire leurs
courses et puis ensuite ils les ramènent
chez eux c'est pas mal ça puisque bon
grâce au service social maman a pu
bénéficier vous savez de la télé télé je
sais plus comment on appelait ça la
téléassistance et les alarmes elle un
petit boîtier qui lui permet en cas de
problème bien d'être relié comment
dirais-je à un service réaffirmer les
valeurs républicaines à l'école c'est
tout l'enjeu des mesures annoncées
aujourd'hui par najat vallaud belkacem
la ministre de l'éducation deux semaines
après les attentats et les incidents
survenus dans certaines écoles de plomb
qui sera mis en action au plus vite
prévoit un volet de formation des
enseignants mais aussi une hausse des
fonds sociaux de 20% pour aider les
enfants en situation de pauvreté
explications réactions mélanie poquet
laïcité citoyenneté valeurs de la
république
depuis les attentats de paris la
ministre de l'éducation les met en avant
et veulent et réaffirmer à l'école du
primaire au lycée
c'est ce qu'elle a fait ce jeudi c'est
nécessaire et ça existe déjà dans le
cadre du programme d'histoire géographie
au collège au lycée aussi et dans le cas
des cônes le programme d'éducation
civique et de cgs au lycée aussi sont
des thèmes qui sont abordés notamment en
troisième en classe de 3e en éducation
civique l'enseignement de la laïcité
d'enseignement de la critique face aux
médias sont des choses qui sont
normalement abordés en classe déjà pour
aider les professeurs aborder ces thèmes
mille enseignants et personnels seront
formés pendant deux jours deuxième
annonce à partir de la rentrée 2015 un
nouvel enseignement moral et civique
sera mis en place
mais aussi un enseignement laïque du
fait religieux
un enseignement laïque du fait religieux
oui c'est quelque chose qui peut sembler
important
ceci dit je sais pas si dans
l'enseignement laïc du fait religieux on
ira jusqu'à l'athéisme ou le fait que
quelqu'un puisse est agnostique donc
je crois qu'il faut attendre de voir les
contenus et en plus comme toujours
adaptés suivant le public auquel on est
confronté les élèves consacreront 300
heures par an l enseignement moral et
civique
ce qui représente une heure par semaine
une annonce jugée incomplète par
certains syndicats comment ça va être
organisée quelle formation
comment vont être organisées les heures
par rapport aux eur déjà existantes
est-ce qu'il va y avoir une augmentation
des heures de présence à l'école c'est
des annonces mais avec quels moyens
derrière la ministre de l'éducation a
annoncé que c'est mon bureau compte 250
millions d'euros sur trois ans nous
allons à présent parler du salon du
lycéen et de l'étudiant qui va se tenir
à versailles ce sera le 24 janvier à
partir de 9 heures 30 au palais des
congrès nous sommes en ligne avec
stéphanie romano bonsoir oui bonsoir
vous êtes la commissaire générale
adjointe aux salons régionaux pour pour
l'étudiant c'est la quatrième fois qu'un
tel évènement va se dérouler sur sur
versailles
un salon dans les yvelines c'était
pertinent ça manquait véritablement
jusqu'à présent oui dans les villes bien
sûr avait failli parce qu'on organise de
nombreux salons à paris qui s'adresse à
un public francilien est vrai qu'il ya
une volonté de nos partenaires locaux
d'organiser un salon de proximité pour
les jeunes du département et qui jusqu'à
présent a rencontré son public j'imagine
sur les précédentes éditions à qui
s'adressent spécifiquement le rendez
vous de samedi justement alors nous nous
adressons avant tout aux jeunes en
première et terminale donc au vif et qui
sont en quête d'enseignement
d'information sur la poursuite d'études
après le bac
donc pour les jeunes qui font en
terminale notamment le moment de dvd
choix sur le portail admission post bac
apb qui vient tout juste d'ouvrir là
depuis le 20 janvier et nous nous
adressons également aux étudiants donc
des jeunes qui sont déjà dans supérieur
et qui souhaitent se réorienter qui ont
peut-être fait de mauvais choix
au mois de septembre qui voit là se sont
rendu compte que ce n'était pas fait
pour eux la filière si j'avais choisi et
qu'il faut être faire autre chose donc
il est encore temps et lorsqu'on vient
et lorsqu'on vient sera un tel salon
justement il faut mieux déjà savoir un
petit peu ce qu'on veut faire où il ya
possibilité justement d'être éclairé
d'être aiguillé sur place il ya une
prise en charge ou les étudiants les
jeunes qui vont bien on va être un peu
perdus s'ils n'ont pas réfléchi avant la
après c'est vrai qu'en fonction des
personnalités
ça va un petit peu dépendre mais non le
talon est ouvert aux jeunes qui ne
savent pas quoi faire et de nombreux
exposants qui seront présents pour
répondre à leurs questions il ya
l'onisep légalement qui est présent et
un stand de l'université d'afrique saint
quentin en yvelines avec toutes les
entités de l'université représentait
donc le salon s'adresse à la fois aux
jeunes qu'ils savent déjà quoi faire
qu'on a un projet et ceux qui ne le
savent pas voilà on espère pouvoir les
aider à faire un choix sur cette journée
non au moins a commencé à le mûrir et
après ils auront peut-être l'occasion
d'aller à des gens des portes ouvertes
ou à trouver d'autres informations ou
aller visiter l'école allait directement
voir établissements n'ira pas uniquement
des stands y ait aussi des conférences
qui seront proposées tout au long de la
journée
oui bien sûr les conférences c'est
toujours à un bon moyen aussi bad poser
vos questions il ya une conférence
nature apb j'en ai parlé un petit peu
tout à l'heure ou alors sur le parcours
universitaire les sciences les métiers
des langues et de l'international ou
encore le management et de commerce
est ce qu'on peut faire un petit état
des lieux rapidement des filières qui
séduisent les étudiants justement vers
quelle branche ce temps de silence
général alors sur un état des lieux
après en fonction des profits
aujourd'hui beaucoup de jeunes vont
quand même à à l'université ça reste la
voie prioritaire l'université encore
aujourd'hui prioritaire non mais c'est
là où il ya le plus d'étudiants me après
sur le salon c'est difficile de vous
répondre parce que les les filières dans
l'enseignement supérieur en france sont
très nombreuses
car les démarches son véhicule en tout
cas la démarche des étudiants est ce que
il s'adapte parce qu'on a souvent parlé
des filières qui accueillait beaucoup
d'étudiants et notamment à l'université
sans pour autant proposer des emplois
derrière
est ce qu'aujourd'hui il ya une prise de
conscience aussi des étudiants qui
cherchent quelque chose un métier une
formation qui va les amener rapidement
un métier est-ce que ça a évolué on
tient il ya une prise de conscience
beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de jeunes
posent la question en disant oui bah je
vais je vais faire ces études là mais
moi à la fin de mes études
qu'est-ce que je peux faire où je peux
travailler est ce que vous allez
m'apporter une insertion professionnelle
voilà alors pas garanti on peut jamais
garantir mais les questions la montre et
s'inquiète des débouchés à avenir après
une dernière question la vie de
l'étudiant ce n'est pas uniquement sa
formation s'est aussi trouvé un job
quelquefois un logement est ce qu'il y
aura des renseignements sur ce salon qui
sera proposé versailles oui oui
notamment grâce à aller au stand de la
ville de versailles
partenaire du salon et qui est présente
avec un stand pour enseigner les jeunes
sur tous ces aspects là de la vie
quotidienne on aura également de
l'information sur le logement la
mutuelle également des infos sur les
bourses voilà tout ce qui concerne
vraiment la vie d'étudiant tout ce qui
concerne la vie de l'étudiant merci à
stéphanie romano ordonne cette
information en pratique donc salon du
lycéen et de l'étudiant 24 janvier dès 9
heures 30 au palais des congrès à
versailles
merci d'avoir été en ligne avec nous
transports et travaux à présent surtout
avec le chantier d'aménagement de la rd
30 à hauteur de plaisir qui débutent les
voix seront doublés une réunion
d'information vient de se tenir pour les
riverains sujet de yolande torres cette
route c'est le matin c'est infernal quoi
on va vous allez mettre dix minutes
alors qu'en temps normal vous mettez
trois minutes pour atteindre
à nationale la rd30 a longtemps été le
calvaire de cette habitante de plaisir
et de bien d'autres
saturé engorgé bouche les termes pour la
décrire ne manquent pas en ce début
d'année le chantier d'aménagement et
d'élargissement de cette route a
commencé un projet attendu depuis 20 ans
c'est impératif que ces travaux démarrés
on en est vraiment très heureux parce
que eh bien on va se rendre compte que
les avoir une fluidité une sécurité qui
va être beaucoup plus grande et certains
plaisirs on s'inquiète qu'il y ait
encore plus de circulation et de toute
façon la circulation il a donc
aujourd'hui plutôt que d'avoir des
voitures qui stagne qui bouchonnent au
niveau de la pollution c'est bien pire
que des voitures qui passent sans
fluidité et qui ne font que traverser
les voies seront doublés entre la rn12
au sud et le rond-point du petit saint
cloud au nord au niveau de cette deux
fois deux voies les giratoires du petit
saint cloud et de jules renier seront
dénivelé tout comme ceux du pressoir et
des gâtines qui seront eux regroupés en
un seul rond point des passerelles aux
piétons cyclistes sont également au
programme
ces aménagements permettront aussi de
décongestionner le centre-ville de
plaisir vers lequel les automobilistes
se reportaient souvent la circulation de
plaisir c'était quand même un peu
engorgé surtout sur le centre vide
ben c'est tout c'est très bien il
fallait venir riveraines de la rd30
christine est là s'inquiètent des
nuisances sonores
moi je ne suis pas du tout gêné par par
le bruit donc ça c'est clair
mais une fois qu'elle passera à deux
fois deux voies
qu'en sera-t-il pas ce cas aujourd'hui
il ya quand les bois qui nous protège
mais après donc pour ça que je suis venu
aujourd'hui pour avoir beaucoup plus
d'information sur le sur le sujet un
sujet bien sûr abordés lors de cette
réunion publique et auquel la mer a
répondu en ce qui concerne les nuisances
sonores
il va y avoir des murs antibruit qui
sont prévus et puis les calculs au
niveau des décibels ont été faits pour
qu'on soit vraiment en dessous même de
la norme actuelle la promesse a été
faite hier les deux sens de circulation
seront maintenues pendant toute la durée
des travaux
coût de l'opération environ 78 millions
euros financés par le conseil général et
la région fin des travaux prévue à l'été
2010 est et cette nouvelle mobilisation
de la fédération française du bâtiment
dans les yvelines lors de la cérémonie
de voeux du président prévue le 29
janvier un spectacle sera joué son nom
c'est le bordel ça va mal finir non
plutôt évocateur il sera question de la
crise qui touche le secteur et des
solutions possibles à apporter une
réunion afin de sensibiliser les seniors
contre le vol s'était il y a quelques
jours un magny les hameaux les
malfaiteurs sont de plus en plus
nombreux à se faire passer pour des
professionnels ou pour des représentants
de l'administration
il faut adopter les bons réflexes pour
ne pas être piégés il était à la fois
intrigué et angoisse et une centaine de
seniors s'est déplacé ce mardi à la
mairie de magny les hameaux à la
recherche de conseils pour déjouer de
probables futurs vols à la fausse
qualité forcément sans plus vulnérables
que quand on est deux fois donc je fâché
assez vigilante a et on se sent
effectivement quelques fois un peu par
agresser et mais on est constamment
appelé au téléphone pour des publicités
pour quelque genre de choses et enfin
mature dit les enfants de 10 et ses
intentions pas dire que pas forcément
dire qu'il est tout seul enfin assérac
on est sollicité en permanence la
gendarmerie et la police municipale se
sont montrés bienveillante en répondant
aux nombreuses questions de l'assistance
ainsi qu'en donnant des conseils ne pas
ouvrir sa porte à n'importe qui faire
très attention demander les cartes
professionnelles personne est obligée de
faire entrer quelqu'un qui ne connaît
pas chez dans sa maison une maison c'est
privé donc quand on n'est pas sûr on ne
fait pas rentrer il faut fermer ses
portes ne jamais laisser ouvert par
exemple le sa porte devant quand on est
dans son jardin des réunions de ce type
ont lieu deux fois par an fin octobre
début novembre et avant les vacances
d'été pour sensibiliser à la sécurité
des biens et des personnes
jusqu'au 14 février l'insee mène sa
campagne de recensement dans plusieurs
villes des yvelines et notamment à la
verrière ils sont une 10
n la barre intervenir sur le terrain
pour récolter les dernières informations
de quelques 6000 habitants mélanie
poquet pause déjeuner pour certains
tournée de recensement pour d'autres
corinne berdych recueille les
informations des habitants du secteur
dans leur lit par deux ailes à 168
logements à recenser
nouveauté cette année les habitants
peuvent répondre sur internet à corps et
puis vous laisser guider par les petites
questions
on vous pose déjà des questions sur le
logement et après de petits
questionnaires pour vous monsieur madame
et puis pour chacun des enfants c'est
rapide en fait non plus dans les 48
heures on ne peut pas tout non à tout le
monde
alors ce matin de jus ce que j'ai fait
un point avec mon responsable je me suis
aperçu qu'il y avait certaines personnes
qui aiment et qui lisez mal donc soit le
numéro 10 street soit le rendre logement
donc c'est pour ça que j'insiste en leur
précisant bien reliés ensemble pour être
sûr qu'ils ont bien compris pourquoi
mais sinon ça fonctionne plus ou moins
bien plus sur internet que papier en cas
d'absence un avis de passage et laisser
les données récoltées sont anonymes et
protégés il y en a certains qui sont un
petit peu brusque et par les questions
quand je pose la question à savoir
combien il ya de personnes dans le
logement c'est arrivé c'est très rare
mais certaines fois et des personnes non
d'érection un petit peu bizarre quoi
mais sinon dans l'ensemble
sincèrement je suis bien accueilli
corinne verdict ce encore 24 logements à
visiter en lui par deux est le plus
petit secteur de la commune les
questionnaires récupérés sont transmis
directement à une c est les données
permettent de définir les dotations de
l'état aux communes mais aussi des
besoins en équipements le recensement se
termine le 14 février
je vous retrouve demain à vendredi pour
la dernière édition de la semaine avec
les mêmes horaires bien sûr excellente
soirée sur téléphiles ce sera notamment
avec florane parfait pour un nouveau
numéro
elle de file et courra demain vendredi